- Hi, I'm Jacqueline Goldsby
I'm chair of the Department
of African-American Studies
here at Yale and I'm really
grateful and glad to welcome you
to our department's
colloquium series Endeavors
and I wanna say a little
bit about this series
to give you a sense of how it
fits in our department's work
and culture and to bring
you into the conversations
that we're going to be
starting this semester.
Typically, we devote Endeavors
to discuss new scholarship
that's shaping the field of
African-Americans studies.
We invite scholars, critics,
artists and activists
beyond Yale and we also spotlight
the work we're doing here
on campus to move the conversations
about the black freedom struggle,
to move the conversations
about all the ways
in which black life effort
has shaped this world.
We bring the newest scholarship
here and we talk about it.
And one of the great things
about this series is that
we focus in typical years
on works in progress.
We wanna see the newest work coming out
and give it the best possible chance
in conversation with
our graduate students,
our undergraduate students,
our colleagues across the
nine different departments
we collaborate with
actively in our PhD program
and with community members too
who can make the time
to come to our sessions.
We talk about works in progress
so that scholars, activists,
artists, critics can get feedback
and produce the best work that
they're capable of making.
But this year is unlike any other year
and you know the conditions we face.
We're facing down a global pandemic
that's killed over 200,000 Americans
and over a million
people across the globe.
And we know that a disproportionate
number of the US deaths
are occurring in communities of color.
We're facing down the
disproportionate killings
and brutalization and mass
incarcerations of black people
at the hands of US police
and judicial systems.
And as Tuesday night's debate
confirmed absolutely, utterly
and irrevocably, we're facing down threats
to American democracy that are
stunning but not surprising
given the Republican parties
concerted strategic efforts
to monopolize all branches
and processes of government.
Given these developments,
the African-American Studies faculty
decided to devote Endeavors to
a single theme this semester,
Black Now: Conversations
for the Revolution
and we decided to invite
scholars, activists and artists
whose work stands up to the challenges
and provides us models for action.
So the questions we're
going to be exploring
in the sessions we've
planned this semester
will teach us about these conditions,
teach us about the healthcare
politics of COVID-19,
teach us about the politics
of mass incarceration
and police brutality and
violence, lethal violence,
teach us about as we will learn today,
voting rights and voting suppression,
but also give us ways to think
about what can we do to act,
what can we do, how can we do it,
what difference can we make?
So in a minute, I will
introduce my colleague
who will introduce our speakers for today
but I wanna first of all give thanks
and lift up our partnership
with the Center for the Study
of Race, Indigeneity and
Transnational Migration, RITM,
as it's known here at Yale.
They've been absolutely
wonderful partners with us,
to co-sponsor this series,
helping us stage this event
for us to convene us together
a community through Zoom.
And I wanna especially
thank the center's director,
Stephen Pitti, who's
a professor of history
and American studies and
ethnicity, race and migration
here at Yale and RITM's
associate director,
Matthew Tanico, who
worked very, very closely
with our colleagues in
African-American Studies
to organize this event.
On the African-American Studies side,
I want to thank Vanessa Epps
who's our newest staff member,
our new senior administrative assistant,
who worked very tirelessly
with Steve Pitti,
with Matt Tanico to
organize the logistics,
thank you so much, Vanessa, for your work.
And I wanna especially thank my colleague,
Professor Crystal Feimster,
who is one of Yale's most
gifted, brilliant historians
who curated this series
and did so much thoughtful,
she knew who to call, she
knew who to reach out to
and made those connections happen
and the series that we have going forward
is going to be a brilliant one
and I wanna thank, Crystal,
I just got to give her a shout out here
for her work, putting this together.
My last words here about
our format, we're in Zoom
so a little Zoom etiquette.
You might've seen an already
clicked, not hopefully,
that you're willing to be recorded.
We are recording these sessions
because we want to have as
intimate a conversation as we can
in the stage here on campus,
but we're lucky to be
thinking and learning
with activist, scholars and critics
who are gonna be coming through this term
we want to make these
conversations available
to a broader public
and so we will be posting
them on Yale's YouTube site.
So we will be recording,
which means please keep your
mics muted, stay on mute
and when it's time for Q and
A, which we want there to be,
we want there to be a robust discussion,
I'll flag now, we're basically
gonna be using the chat
for you to submit your questions
and then we'll present
those to our speaker today
for deeper conversation.
But a little later on,
Professor Crystal Feimster
will explain how that function
will work but that's how
we're going to move through
our time together here.
So with that, I wanna turn things over
to Professor Crystal Feimster
who will introduce our
guest speaker today.
Thanks.
(upbeat music)
- Is this America, the land of the free
and the home of the brave?
Our lives be (indistinct)
daily because we want to live
as decent human beings in America.
♪ Ain't gonna let nobody ♪
♪ Turn me around ♪
♪ Don't let them turn ♪
♪ Ain’t gonna let nobody ♪
♪ Turn me around ♪
♪ I'm gonna keep on
walking, keep on talking ♪
♪ Marching up to freedom, yeah ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
- [Man] All types of conniving
methods are still being used
to prevent Negros from
becoming registered voters.
♪ Ain't gonna let no races ♪
♪ Turn me around ♪
♪ Ain’t gonna let no races ♪
♪ I'm gonna keep on
walking, keep on talking ♪
♪ Marching, yeah ♪
- [LaTosha] Today is a concerted
poor native effort y'all
to suppress the vote.
- It started when Africans were enslaved
and forced to come to this country.
There has never been a period
of time in this country
that there was not voter suppression.
♪ Ain’t gonna let injustice ♪
♪ Turn me around ♪
- We are going to vote.
♪ Ain’t gonna let injustice ♪
♪ Turn me around ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm gonna keep on walking ♪
- Can't stop, won't stop.
Can't stop, won't stop.
♪ Keep on talking ♪
♪ Marching on freedom, yeah ♪
- We have to define the job description,
we have to define the agenda.
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Ain't gonna let nobody ♪
♪ Turn me around ♪
- This is about power.
This is about our power
and ultimately when we show up, we win.
♪ Keep on walking, keep on talking ♪
♪ Marching up to freedom land ♪
♪ I'm gonna keep on
walking, keep on talking ♪
♪ Marching up to freedom land ♪
♪ No justice, no peace ♪
♪ Justice, no peace ♪
♪ I said if I hold just
a little while longer ♪
♪ Fight on just a little while longer ♪
♪ Fight on, fight on, fight on ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I gonna let (indistinct) ♪
- Black voters matter,
black voters matter.
- [LaTosha] Black voters.
- [Congregation] Matter.
- I come here to urge every person
under the sound of my
voice to go to the polls
on the 3rd of November
and vote your conviction.
- That was really powerful
and I know that LaTosha
is gonna talk to us
a little bit about her music
and the freedom music that she's producing
and I think that's a piece
that's gonna be on her newest album,
but I'm gonna let her speak
more specifically to that.
But I wanna take a moment
before we get into this conversation
to thank the African-American
Studies community
and the RITM community for
everything that they've done
to make this possible.
I wanna thank Emmanuel who
is our tech person today
helping us out but I also
wanna thank everybody
who's agreed to participate,
from my colleagues here
at Yale and beyond.
And I think Jackie pretty
much covered the basis
but I just wanna sort of reaffirm that
and my gratitude to our chair
for also insisting that we
make this happen this semester
because it's important work
and important conversations
that we need to have.
So we are fortunate and really blessed
to be able to our series
with LaTosha Brown
and Aimee Meredith Cox in conversation.
LaTosha Brown is the co-founder
of Black Voters Matter Fund,
a power building southern based
civic engagement organization
that played an instrumental role
in the 2017 Alabama US Senate race
and will no doubt play an important
and necessary role in
this coming election.
Ms. Brown is a principal owner
of TrueSpeaks Consulting Inc,
a philanthropy advisory consulting
firm in Atlanta, Georgia.
And for more than 25 years,
she has served as a consultant
and advisor for individual
donors, government,
public foundations, and private donors
who are committed to doing
social justice work so,
but she's also an amazing jazz singer
and we're gonna get to benefit
from a little bit of her
musical talent I think today.
Aimee Meredith Cox is my
amazing and brilliant colleague
and friend who's an associate professor
in the Department of
African-American Studies
and Anthropology.
Her research and teaching interests
lie at the intersection of
anthropology, black studies
and performance studies
and black feminist theory.
Cox's first monograph,
"Shapeshifters: Black Girls
and the Choreography of
Citizenship," has taught me much
and if you haven't read that
book, you need to read it.
It is a prize winning book,
she received the 2016
Victor Turner Book Prize
in Ethnographic Writing
and Honorable Mention
from the 2016 Gloria Anzaldua Book Prize.
And now I'm actually gonna turn it over
to these amazing, brilliant black women.
- Oh, hello, hello.
Thank you so much, Crystal,
thank you so much, Jackie
for setting us up.
LaTosha.
- How are you?
- I just have to tell
you what a gift it is
to be in conversation with
you especially right now.
I cannot think of a better person
to not just help us
think through this moment
but to help us develop that
deeper level of knowing
that allows us to comprehend
how we feel in this moment
and what to do about
that, what action to take.
So I wanna first thank you
for carving out the time
to be with us here this morning.
I know you have traveled
and you're still traveling
all over the country.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
I think it's four states
in the past 10 days, 11
events in the past 10 days
and so so grateful for your
time and for your energy
and thank you for being
here and talking with me.
So last night,
and this was actually after
we had gotten off the phone,
LaTosha last night, I was thinking about
how to open our conversation
and what to say about this present moment.
And so I'm sure you can
name right along with me
everything that crossed my mind,
and Jackie already pointed
to many of those things,
the ongoing dishonoring
of Breonna Taylor's life.
The fact that our president
or the president of the United States
sent out of clarion call
for white supremacists
on national TV blatantly.
The generations long
trajectory of the Supreme Court
upon the death of Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
As you all know all too well,
the gutting of voting rights
and our civil liberties, and
the many, many, many, many,
many, too many ways to name
that black life has been
and continues to be snatched.
The pandemic, state sanctioned murder,
withholding of life saving resources,
environmental devastation.
This is where I started to name,
this is where I started to
start and then I stopped
because I believe we have
to make our arms wider,
we have to hold a different
type of space simultaneously,
we have to claim something different.
We have to claim those
combinations of forces
and histories that allow
you and I to even be here
in conversation today.
We have to name for whom
we are holding this space
and who is holding us in this space,
this is where we have to start now.
So we will, of course, we
will address all the things,
all the things, we will talk
about what we are up against,
we will talk about black
voters matter and suppression
and resistance in the face of everything
that we are struggling through and with.
But I wanna open this space
from a place that reminds
us of our inheritance,
our inheritance of strength,
fierce intellect, courage,
innovation, community
care and of course love.
This is where we want to end up,
this is where we have to start.
So I want to call into this
space, into our conversation,
two people that I know we both
hold dear, our mutual friend
and fierce advocate for
black women and girls,
Tynesha McHarris and Angela Davis.
- Ashay, ashay.
- Hmm.
Tynesha says, "My power and my humanity
are not experienced through who I control
but through who I love
and am accountable to.
My power and my humanity
are not experienced through who I control
but through who I love
and am accountable to."
Angela Davis, a little bit longer,
"The work of the political activist
inevitably involved a certain tension
between the requirements
that positions be taken
on current issues as they arise
and the desire that one's contributions
will somehow survive the ravages of time.
In this sense, the most
difficult challenge
facing the activist is to respond fully
to the needs of the moment
and to do so in such a way
that the light one attempts
to shine on the present
simultaneously illuminates the future."
- Hmm, powerful.
So, LaTosha,
these words remind me of
my first vision of you,
which is that of a traveler,
and so let me explain what I mean by that.
I feel that you are rooted and nurtured
by the lessons of the past,
the work and blueprint
etched in our very spirits
by those who breathed air
on this troubled Earth
long, long before us.
Your work at the same time
sit squarely and resolutely
in the urgency of the now
as you mobilize all of this
with a prophetic imagination
that is gazing towards our black futures
and you know there is no real distinction
between these three planes.
You show us so clearly how to
live in all of them at once,
how to do work in all of them at once
guided by the fierce undeterred
love for black communities
that Tynesha talks about
that as a source of light
that illuminates how you
manifest accountability
in your political,
intellectual and activist work.
So I honor you and I wanna
start with that grounding,
with those roots, black
voters matter is necessary
for all of the reasons we will get into
but I would love for you to
situate black voters matter
in a larger history because I
want people to understand that
as powerful as the work is, it
is part of a broader strategy
for manifesting black
political power, right?
And let me be clear, not empire building,
but black political power
and so we know that voting
is in this moment, especially,
so that we can come up
and fight another day,
live to fight another day,
but I want you to talk about
how you see Black Voters Matter
as part of this longer political project
that you've been involved in
for decades and decades and decades.
And lastly I'll just say,
how you see black women,
the mobilization of black
women and your relationships
with intergenerational
groups of black women
being a part of this foundation.
- Hmm.
♪ Oh freedom, oh freedom ♪
♪ Oh freedom over me, over me ♪
♪ And before I be a slave,
I'll be buried in my grave ♪
♪ And go home to my Lord and be free ♪
♪ I woke up this morning
with my mind set on freedom ♪
♪ Oh, I woke up this morning
♪ Hallelu, hallelu, hallelujah ♪
♪ Well, the first thing I did right ♪
♪ Was the day I started to fight ♪
♪ Keep your eyes on the
prize and hold on, hold on ♪
You know, I want to start in those songs,
just what came up in my spirit
because I wanted us to get
grounded in the history.
That we think about, you know
we think about kind of the,
we have movement as a
cerebral kind of interaction
that we're thinking about
what were they thinking,
what were their strategies?
We think about the policy that was shaped,
we think about the laws
and the Voting Rights Act
that this is the 55th
anniversary of its passage,
but most importantly y'all,
what it was and what grounds me
at makes me connect it is that
the spirit of the movement
continues to live in me
and I think what it does
is it actually passes down
through generation and generation.
I think it transcends time, space,
that there's something
fundamental that is connected,
I feel connected to, that is
greater than the US government,
that there's something that
is fundamentally greater
than what it seen, those
forces that are beyond
what I may even think
that I have the strength
to come up against.
I believe that my work
is rooted and grounded
as those people before
me, as my ancestors,
and something that was
greater, that is really driven
by our love and our power and
our passion around humanity.
Even when we talk about
the voting rights movement
and the civil rights movement,
we really think about
that in the context of
what political rights came out of it,
but fundamentally, people
weren't doing all of that work
just for the right to vote,
just to participate in this system,
they were literally reclaiming
and literally standing in their agency
around their humanity,
making sure that their
humanity was recognized
and appreciated and valued.
And so as I think about the
work of Black Voters Matter
where we're certainly a
power building organization,
it is to.
What we want to do is literally
be able to remind people
that their power doesn't necessarily come
from the US government
or any nation state,
that fundamentally in the
very creation of who they are
in their spirit, they in fact have value
and that they in fact have agency
and that any decision
that is made about them
and their families and the community,
they have the power to shape that.
And man, when it does not exist
or when that's threatened,
they have the right to demand that change.
And so you know my work,
I see our work doing now
in Black Voters Matter, I so
apologize you all, we are,
can you hear me?
- Yes, we can hear you, okay, okay.
- So we are on the bus.
I thoroughly apologize.
Let me just give some context
for people who are watching.
We are working and you were
saying that we went to,
in the last 10 days, no,
it was actually half,
that was five days, right?
It was five days.
We've had 12 events and we're moving
and I wanted this discussion
and being a part of the
discussion is really important.
As we're doing this discussion,
I want y'all to know
that I'm also engaged
in the work right now,
that we're actually headed
to, two hours from here,
we're in North Carolina
and headed to another space
that we're doing rallies
and I'll share something about that.
I am sitting here on the
blackest bus in America
that we go around from
communities to community
that we spread two things,
that we're committed to spreading
love and building power.
And so this organization
was founded in 2016
by Cliff Albright and
I, and what we wanted
is we wanted to build and
how could we, for years,
as organizers in the deep South,
we would sit around and think,
how can we really be able
to support movement building
and institutional building?
And so we created this
organization in 2016.
We had the audacity to believe
that we would come up with
some money from somewhere
and sometimes you have to move
because we have been able to be successful
and been able to raise money for a fund.
We created the Black
Voters Matter Fund first
and Black Voters Matter
Capacity Building Institute
which is a (c)(3) for the explicit purpose
of the way that our
theory of change is that
the way that you build power
is you build power from the ground up,
and that the way that you do that is that
we're not an empire builder,
which means how about understanding
of how I think about it
is we're not going around the country
trying to get Black Voters
Matter chapters everywhere,
we don't have no interest in that.
Our goal is to strengthen
and build the capacity of
existing infrastructure,
that in every community
that there's infrastructure.
Matter of fact, even if we can go back
to the enslavement of Africans,
there was always a system of communicating
whether the master or the
folks knew, the overseer knew,
there was always a system
of being able to share food,
to share information, to
even to be able to gather.
And so there's always an ecosystem,
there's always a infrastructure
within our communities.
Our model was how can we be of
service and offering to build
and support the infrastructure
that's already there
those organizations,
those groups, those folks
that at the end of the day,
if something happens in that community,
they are the first responders.
That we felt that that's
who needed the support.
And so we think of ourselves
more like special ops,
that the work is already going,
the soldiers are already on the ground,
our goal is to come in and show up
and say what it is that you
need to be able to provide that.
And so in doing that, there's
a couple of things that we do
and how we provide that.
One, we provide resources.
We provide direct grants to organizations.
In 2018, we funded over 180
groups almost a million dollars
that we provided direct resources
and I wanna talk a
little bit about, Aimee,
how we did it a little bit different.
I come out of philanthropy and
I've worked in philanthropy
for the last 15 years of
my life and Cliff Albright,
who's also the other co-founder
has worked in philanthropy as well.
And oftentimes in philanthropy,
there is a particular kind of way
that those of us who have
been engaged in philanthropy
in the social justice world,
it doesn't feel good often.
In many circumstances you
feel like you gotta swear,
one, you gotta prove yourself,
you always got to prove yourself
that you are worthy to receive resources.
Two, it often feels like
you're held at a different
standard, not felt it's true
that you held at a different standard
than some of your white counterparts.
And three, if you're not doing the work
the very way that they
think you should do the work
because obviously they
know how to movement build
better than you do, right?
That if you don't do the
work in that context,
that it's something fundamentally wrong
and so what winds up happening,
it creates this dance,
that you have to be
not your authentic self
or literally talk about
the authentic work.
You have to create and make yourself,
you have to contort yourself
to fit into this kind of criteria
of which they have set out for it.
So one of the things that we
did, we wanted to be different
and so even as we go into communities,
we do research before we go
into communities, we do advance.
Before we literally did
anything, Cliff Albright and I
went around the seven states
in the South and we listen.
We went from state to state to listen.
People know what they need,
people know what they want.
They know power and so fundamentally,
I think one of the problems is that
folks are always telling,
particularly black folks,
what to do.
They wanna tell us what to
do, what we should be doing,
what we need to think instead
of actually taking the time
to listen, that there is power
in the listening of people
that can actually shape and tell you
what it is that they prioritize.
They can also in your hearing,
if you're really listening,
what they're not saying,
you can be able to hear.
And so I'm raising that because
part of the way that
we've shifted our funding
and the way that we approached it is that
the groups that we had done work with
like criteria is one.
Groups were rooted in community,
to that community credibility,
they had community credibility.
May have been existing
organizations have a 501(c)(3),
some of 'em were churches,
some of 'em were
reproductive rights groups,
some of them were prison reform or,
some of them were the three ol' sisters
in the church that just makes sure
that everything in that
community keeps rolling.
And so fundamentally when we
would identify those groups
and talk to other folks
that actually we were able
to see those three criteria,
the first thing we did is we
would give them a mini grant.
No paperwork, no questions.
It was amazing.
They would say, "Well, what
did I gotta do for this?"
And a matter of fact they were suspect,
like, "Why y'all giving us some money?"
It was like because we're investing
in what you have already done.
It was like, well what
I gotta do for this?
It was like nothing, that
you've already done the work.
What we wanna do is
give you this investment
because what we've heard
from your community
is that you will always serve
and show up when people need you.
And so what that did is
it broke the dynamic,
it shifted the paradigm
of this idea of that
people have to prove themselves to you.
And it shifted the paradigm
and broke up this space
around this grantee-grantor relationship.
We didn't want a
grantee-grantor relationship
because there's a power dynamic in that.
What we wanted is we wanted
a partnership relationship.
That to recognize that
we are coming to you
to be supportive to you,
that you in fact are leading the work,
that you are in the
fact of who we all need.
We are dependent on you in
North Carolina and in Alabama
and Mississippi and so
part of our approach,
even just initially coming in
to be able to provide a mini grant,
it wasn't so much about the money
but what the money did is
it changed the power dynamic
in terms of how people
normally get resources
and so it opened up the space.
I remember one of the groups
that we're working with
in Southwest Georgia, he was
so kinda suspect at first
he said, "You know what?
I don't want a grant, I
just want a megaphone."
We're like, "You want what?" (laughs)
He said, "I want a megaphone."
So we're like, I mean, okay,
so we bought a megaphone for him.
Literally the day he got the megaphone,
he's a leader in the NAACP
in Southwest Georgia,
one of the counties in Southwest Georgia,
the day we got the megaphone,
he organized some of the
folks that he worked with
and went and took over the city hall.
We were like, well, if we had known that,
we would've bought you
two megaphones, right?
And so part of the, it wasn't so much as
and after that time, we have
been supporting his work.
Money matters but really
intention matters most.
How you show up in this space for groups,
are you showing up in a way
that you are affirming them
or are you showing up in a way that says,
once again you got to
prove to me black people
that you are worthy,
that you are valuable,
or do you show up in a way that says
we see the value in what you're doing.
What we have found is
that the mini grants,
the mini grants are just a start,
what we have found that even
in that conversation quickly,
the conversation is never around money,
that most of the groups
that we're working with,
it's not about money because
we changed that dynamic
from the beginning to let
them know, even for us,
it's not about money,
even though that's one of
the things that we offer,
we wanted to change the paradigm
in which there's this
monetary exchange and say, no,
the money is significant
to the extent that it
helps you do your work.
What we wanna hear about is your work
and we'll figure out what we need to do
and what kind of support you need
so that we can continue to do that.
And so even in our funding
process there is a simple,
so that we can track and keep records,
there's a simple process now
that when people fill
out for our mini grants,
they can get grants up to
$10,000 do their JLTV work
or their power building work.
The work that they have deemed
that's important around power building.
What's really interesting around it is,
and this is hard for people
to really conceive of,
just recently some of our partners
that we know are doing
really, really good work.
You know, we had given a grant to them,
one of them in Alabama in
February and so we called
and we said, "Simba, we haven't
gotten anything from you,
we see you doing all this work,
how are you paying for it?"
He said, "I'm paying for
it out of my pocket."
We're like, "Well why are you doing that?"
And he said, "Because I didn't
wanna come back to y'all,
I already got some money from y'all."
I was like, "That's not who we are."
I'm raising that because
philanthropy has set up a structure
and a particular kind of culture
that people constantly feel
like they are some way indebted
or some way that they
can't come back and ask.
The way our process is we told them,
whenever you need
resources, you come to us.
If we ain't got it, we just
gone tell you we ain't got it
but I can guarantee you if
there's a will and a way,
we're gonna help you to figure out
how we can get that money
even we fundraise it together.
So even part of our process
is to really be able to
destroy all of those mechanisms
that have helped us to feel
marginalized and undervalued
and so that people have
a, it's so interesting,
that is like the toughest part
to really be able to convince folks
that literally, it's
an open rolling cycle.
Tell us when you need what you need
and it is amazing the level of trust,
the level of expertise, the
way that communities, you know,
that's why this whole
fallacy that we're hearing
around people get money, they're abusive.
We have put so much, we've
wrapped up so much a frame,
this capitalist frame that centered money,
that makes people respond to
it in a certain kind of way.
If you take that out, if
you take the value out
and literally focus it
on the value on the work
and the routine of the work,
it changes the dynamics all together.
We have had a excellent
experience with our partners
and we move millions of dollars, right?
We trust them, they trust us.
We even know that oftentimes
the money that we give,
part of the time, I'll give one example
for people to understand
that it's not about money.
A good example I wanna share
is some work that we did in Tennessee.
In Tennessee there was a
community oversight board.
There was a group in the community
that after several murders
of black men and black women
in that community, they
wanted to come together
and put a community
oversight board together.
Now what was interesting is that
FOP put millions of dollars,
the Fraternal Order of Police
put millions of, the police
union, millions of dollars
against this campaign because of course
they didn't want this oversight board
'cause in many ways we
know that law enforcement,
there are many in law enforcement
that don't want any accountability,
in particular accountability
to the black community.
And so when we got involved,
we were just started
and we got involved and we
were their largest funder
and I think that we gave them a total of
somewhere under 30,000,
I can't remember exactly
what the amount is
but it was under 30,000.
They were up against millions of dollars
and the most powerful union
in lobbying in Tennessee.
Guess who won?
They won because all they
needed it's not money,
we think it's oftentimes
that it is the money
that change the politics,
no, it's the political wheel.
If you can get the resources
to people who are organized,
they are organizations that are doing work
that you can't even pay
them for their work.
That fundamentally what they are offering,
it doesn't even have a tag to it, right?
There are people that are giving,
when people are giving out of
their spirit and their passion
and their belief system, that
is what is transformative.
Money is oftentimes limited
because it's transactional.
And so while we recognize
that money is needed
as a tool to help build
the infrastructure,
we also recognize that
it is not the driver,
it is those things that
create transformation
that are the driver.
So Aimee, I know that
was a long way around
not answering your question.
- No,
I intentionally opened it that way
because I knew through that,
you would take us there.
I knew that would just allow you
to take us all the way there.
So many lessons, I mean,
that was a whole sermon
but so many lessons.
Building on what's already there.
The idea that you have to come into,
particularly a black
community and change it,
but we know this, we know
this from our history.
Life is already there, the
transformation is already there
so building on that foundation
and it's not about the money, right?
The foundation or thereness
that allows for change
doesn't need money necessarily
and so to think differently
about how we access resources.
Another thing I wanna highlight
is how you have traveled,
now, you're traveling around the country,
we know this 'cause you're
on this bus with this, sorry,
janky Wi-Fi, but also you have traveled
for many different institutions.
You have traveled through philanthropy,
which I myself think of one
of the widest most white
and conservative and
capitalistic structures
and you have found a way
to renegotiate the terms
of what philanthropy can
do in our communities.
So when we think about the
501(c)(2) in our neighborhood
that's not doing anything,
everybody knows it's not doing anything,
but keeps getting grant money
and you come into that
same community and say, no,
it's really that
grandmother down the street
who's taking care of all the children,
who's providing food, that's
where the money needs to go
and rethinking how we think
about resources in our community
and what looks like in our communities.
One thing that I want you to
expand on and move us into
thinking about the work
specifically right now
in this moment around black
voters matter is listening.
And I just have to tell
you as an anthropologist,
as a black feminist anthropologist,
how jealous I am of you
on this black bus right now.
I'm tempted to leave my class--
- A black bus in America, by the way.
- And you know, because my whole reason
for coming into the
discipline of anthropology
speaking about, you know,
if we're talking about
colonial projects, you know,
these white institutions,
you couldn't get much deeper than that
than anthropology but for me
coming through anthropology
was about a black feminist
model of being in community
and the way that you talk about.
You don't just come into a community,
you research that community,
you embed yourself in that
community and you listen.
And so I'm wondering if
you could talk to us about,
from your listening because we
hear a lot on "CNN", "MSNBC",
reading blog posts the way
people talk about voting
in the black community
or black communities,
the way that black folks are
or are not thinking about voting,
the way that Trump has created
the voting electoral process,
completely de-legitimized
the electoral process
and how maybe people
are responding to that.
Our choice or the undecided
vote in the black community
not being about a vote for Trump or Biden
but whether we vote or not.
Like these are all sort of
the narrative around voting
and black communities
and you are traveling across
the country talking to folks.
And I'm wondering if you
could give us a sense of
how the people you are on the ground with,
you're literally on the ground
with right now in this bus
traveling through the country,
how they are imagining their vote,
how they're thinking
about their relationship
to the democratic process.
The kinds of conversations you're having
and what we can learn that
we're perhaps not learning
when we're watching the news
or through mainstream media.
Like, what is the real word on the street,
what are people feeling
and talking about and struggling with?
- In essence, what is real in the field?
And so what I would like to
do, I wanna show a quick clip,
Crystal, if you can show,
I'm gonna show a quick clip
and then I'll come back
to answer the question.
(upbeat music)
- We got power.
We're about to get ready and
launch our We Got Power tour.
- Cliff and I are going on
the blackest bus in America,
we're hitting the streets again.
- [Cliff] We're gonna be going
through at least 12 states,
maybe more, I'm just really excited.
- Now it's a little bit different
time with this COVID-19,
we've gotta wear a mask, we've
got to be socially distant
but we are very committed
that we've got to get on
the streets and inspire
and encourage our people in a
way that are socially distant.
- Ready to hit the road,
ready to see our folks,
ready to be socially
distant, ready to mask up.
- [LaTosha] On our way to Pennsylvania,
we'll be there for two days
and then we're headed
to Ohio to Cleveland.
- We're just gonna be just
spreading a lot of love
and building a lot of power.
- The very last day,
we're gonna be out here
on the ground in these streets
because our people need us.
Can't stop, won't stop.
- Register to vote.
You can even request your
online vote by mail ballot
by clicking the link
or by scanning our QR
code with your camera.
Vote early, vote today
'cause we got power.
- You know the quarantine
in addition to that,
having the one bus, we actually have two
and they have some babies
so we have 20 mini buses,
baby buses that are in 11
states that we're going in
and I wanna talk about that too
because I mean it was just a bus, right?
But it's not the bus that makes the magic,
it's actually the message.
And I don't know if you
all were able to see,
I wanna kind of share one of the incidents
that happened early on when
we started on every bus,
every tour, this was our third tour.
Every tour that we've done
on the bus, you will always,
you will never see a Black Voters Matter
and it doesn't have love and power
and that's because our work
is rooted in those two values,
love and power, everything that we do
is in between those two.
And so when we're talking about the work
of what we're hearing on the ground,
we approach the work from a
perspective and a place of
that everybody has power,
we're just there remind them.
Not to give them power
but to remind them that they have power
and to be able to situate
that and pull it out
and that everybody is deserving of love
and sometimes we have to
be reminded of that as well
and to be reminded that we are loved.
And so in this process I
think it's really important
that when we've been talking
to people going on the ground,
you know, as I said earlier,
I do want people to recognize
the most powerful tool as an
organizer is listening someone.
And I didn't say to listen,
I intentionally said listen
someone and what I mean by that
it is oftentimes when I
think about, you know,
think about how many times,
everybody always got some
advice for black folks.
What we need to do, what
we need to be thinking.
I mean, everybody got some
advice about what we doing wrong,
what we need to be doing, X, Y, Z
when the truth of the matter,
we have extraordinarily well.
The fact that right now that
even when I talk about voting,
just take this, that right
now black people vote
on par to our white counterparts.
In addition to that,
black women actually have
the highest voting turnout
than any constituency
group in this country.
The significance of that is
and like that white voters have received
the majority of the economic, political
and social benefits of this system.
The fact that black folks,
it's only been 50 years,
when we've seen our vote
be supported and protected
through the Voting Rights
Act for us to be on par,
it is actually extraordinary.
The fact that we have to go through hell
just to be able to get our
registration, to go to vote.
I'm saying that because there's
oftentimes this narrative
as if black folks ain't voting,
yes we are, we're voting
at the same level as
our white counterparts
who are reaping the
majority of the benefits.
So we've got to shift the narrative
to literally as my
grandmother used to say,
speak life into people
instead of death in the folks,
speak life, let's talk about what it is
not just frame us from a victim
but frame us from the perspective
of we've got more to do
and certainly we have to expand
but also democracy should
not be laid at the feet
or on the back of black folk.
When I think about this country
and I think about the founders
of this country, Aimee,
the founders of this country
had some brilliant ideas about,
theoretical, about democracy
but they certainly were
limited in their vision
so much so that they
couldn't even see you and I
or Jacqueline or any
of the others that are,
many of us on this,
they didn't even have enough
vision to be able to see
and recognize our humanity.
But at the end of the day,
so I consider them, yes,
they were the founders of this country
but when I say the founders of democracy,
I think about those
folks in Selma, Alabama,
that was on the Edmund Pettus Bridge
that literally pushed this country
to be what she needed to be,
to push this country to
really be able to deal with
what is the foundation of democracy.
If the vote is not
afforded to all citizens
then how can we really call
this truly a democracy?
And so in that space, I
think we also have to shift
how we're having this conversation
of what is at stake now,
we have to shift how we talk about voting
and we have to shift around
how we engaging around this.
And so as I talk about
listening, part of the piece is,
you know I remember a couple of years ago
when I was first starting
being an organizer,
I went to a basketball court
and I asked this young man to,
I was registering people to vote
and he was very dismissive.
He was like, I'm not
registering with X, Y, Z.
And I started to try to evangelize him,
to the tell him how many people had died
and why he needed to vote and
people have paid the price.
And I mean, I was just
like passionate with it,
I was like preaching a sermon
and he said to me calmly,
"So are you asking me
that I need to put my faith in a system
that doesn't even believe in me,
is that what you're saying to me?"
What was that gonna say to that?
I didn't have an ounce at a time.
It took me about 15 years
to develop my answer.
I got an answer now, but
it took me about 15 years
to really sit with that
because truth in what he said.
And I mean he went on, I mean,
it was a number of things,
he was a brilliant brother.
I remember he went on to talk
about they're all folks voting
and we've elected this and my grandmother
and them elected these folks
and look at my community,
look at it right now.
Like he literally
challenged me on the spot
and so over a number of years,
I can still hear that
brother, matter of fact,
he has been my greatest
teacher around voting
because it was in my listening to him
that I had to really deal
and wrestle with the truth
in what he was saying because
everything he said was true
and I say that that is
actually in the shaping
of how I approach the work.
So when we're going out talking
to folks in the communities
or on the streets and they
say, "I'm not gonna vote
'cause I don't believe
that my vote matters
or my voice matters,
they gonna do what they wanna do anyway,
you see how my community operates."
Instead of me trying to evangelize them
and to get them to convince
them to believe in a system,
the first thing that I say is,
I'm not trying to convince
you to believe in a system,
I want you to believe
in yourself, number one.
Number two, I wanna know what
is it that you care about
'cause I never say that people apathetic,
I have not had a single conversation
with any person that didn't
care about something.
And so instead of the
conversation be around voting,
the conversation shifts to
what is it that you care about?
And then when it shifts
to what they care about
and I listen them, I can understand
what it is that they wanna see.
And they usually connect from
the listening of what they care about
and I say, "Well, okay, you care about it,
and you're so passionate about it,
what is it that you wanna see different?"
Which then goes into their vision
and then they'll go into
that vision and say,
"Well, I wanna see, my cousin got 20 years
and this other dude cross
town, he only got six months
and I wanna see something different.
I wanna see that DA."
I was like, "Well, what
do you wanna happen?"
"I want that DA that did
that to him, he got to go"
Exactly, so if you want
him to go, guess what,
guess how he gets in power?
He's elected.
The point is I make the
connection of voting
on how it can impact
them getting the decision
or whatever it is that they
want that they care about.
Oftentimes we've had voting so far up here
and part of it is because people really,
there has been an effort
in this country for us
not to really lean into
understanding the power of voting.
And it isn't by accident
that 45% of the population don't
participate in the process.
There is an active effort for
people just to be proxies,
just get somebody to vote for you
and go about your business.
We've got to shift the narrative
from voting being about participation
to voting being about power.
And so even in that conversation
what I share with them is
I will say to them, "I
actually agree with you.
When you say that you frustrated
and people been in office
ain't done anything,
you absolutely right, I'm with you.
I believe it, I felt it, I
feel the same frustration."
And so what we have to do is
really be able to show folks
have a honest conversation
about the limitations of voting
but also to be able to get them to see
what power leverage it does have.
And so if we're bringing
it from a perspective
of being honest, saying,
yes, you're absolutely right.
Voting is not the panacea,
I'll be the first one to say,
voting ain't the panacea,
it ain't the end all be all,
it's not gonna solve
a lot of our problems.
It was frustrating to me
when I would hear people say
someone had gotten murdered,
it was like, well, just vote.
No, we ain't gotta just vote
but vote is one of the pieces,
is one vehicle and one leverage to power.
And so fundamentally we
shift the conversation
that the conversation isn't
just about participation,
it's about power and then
not go into this conversation
to say, I don't know about
you, but LaTosha Brown,
every decision that is
made about me and my life,
I need to be a part of that decision.
How do you feel about it?
Make a decision about (indistinct),
well, somebody's gonna be.
It's just like a basketball
game which is all the time,
a team is gonna win, the question is
which team is going to
really reduce the harm
happening to your community?
Yes, it might not be
the perfect candidate,
it might not be the
perfect political party
but fundamentally and quite quickly,
it's been very, very rare
that I've had the opportunity
to vote for the ideal candidate.
I see voting a tactical strategy
for a larger goal of what I
seek which is to reduce the harm
in my community that's
happening right now,
to hold people accountable,
who are harming my community
and to also put people
in place and position
that actually have some alignment
with the agenda that I
have with my community,
but I don't stop there.
While I'm doing that, I am also building
and building a new framework
for us to collectively vision.
I am building new networks
for us to really be able
to amass the kind of power
that we can actually talk about
the replacement of systems,
that we can start envisioning
what is the next thing.
And so my work, when I'm on the streets
and when we're talking to folks,
I think there's three points takeaways.
One, there's an authentic
conversation with folks
around the limitation but also the power,
the leverage of voting.
Two, that we make a specific connection
around what it is that they care about,
that how voting can impact that.
It's hard for you to
get people to care about
the presidential election
when they've lost control
of their school board.
So you start from where people are.
And then the third thing is
I think really being able to get people
to shift the focal point
so that the focal point
isn't about the candidates
and it's not about the political parties
but it's about the people.
That fundamentally what
the constitution says,
it doesn't say we the political parties,
it doesn't say we the
candidates, it say we the people.
And so over time, I think
we put so much focus
on how do we amass political parties,
the power of political parties?
How do we find the
candidate that's gonna come
and save us all that we've gotten away
from the basic foundation of democracy
that the power always should rest
and reside with the people.
- Yes, and I want, you know,
so I'm looking at the chat
and the chat is mirroring exactly
what I'm thinking in this moment.
You mentioned the
skepticism that many voters
or potential voters have.
I also wanna talk about the real fears
and how we can understand
what the threat is.
So I'll just in terms
of my own experience,
my family in Ohio, people
are terrified of voting
and so when we talk
about voter suppression,
I know that means something
very different in each state
and it manifests in different ways.
There are states and folks
that are more vulnerable than others
but I'm wondering if
you could speak to that
and I'm gonna pull up, as
you're thinking about that,
there's a couple of
comments that speak to that
really thinking about,
well when we talk about voter suppression,
what does that look like?
How do we understand the
real threat to bodily harm
and violence that folks are dealing with
and considering as part of the reason
to really wanna protect themselves
and then what can we do?
But I'm gonna read you
a comment from the chat.
This is Deborah Wells who
does a lot of voting activism.
She says, "I'm concerned that
when I go to early voting,
there are white
supremacists at the library
and I must record their behavior
and possibly the armed in response.
Everyone in Florida is
armed, need it come to that."
And just in conversation with Deborah,
we have another comment
that's related to that.
"There are some social science research
that shows that police
contact not even arrest,
just contact is a significant
deterrent to black voting.
Can you talk about how you
think about arming communities
to resist state violence
that is actively trying to
disempower or even kill them?"
So we're having these questions
that are really thinking about
kind of the extent of voter suppression
and what that means as acts of violence
and how are black
communities processing this,
how are they thinking about resistance?
What are your ideas around it?
And can you outline for us
what those threads really
look like and what can we do,
what can we do and what states,
where should we be putting
our energy and our attention?
- I'm back.
- Okay, alright, LaTosha did you hear--
- I heard the question.
- Okay.
I heard the question.
- [Aimee] Okay, okay.
- I am on the back
roads of North Carolina,
welcome to the bus, y'all. (laughs)
Let me share a personal experience
that happened two days ago.
Two days ago ago, I
wanted to show the bus.
We've got, you know,
it's a moving billboard
and you may not have been
able to see the details
but the way that on the bus it has,
we got power in huge, huge letters.
It has black fist, love, power,
black people all around the bus.
It's about us all of these messages
that are affirming
message for black people
and even the we got power in the middle of
it's a black fist rays.
And so on the highway, it
gets its own share of love
and stares and everything in between
but we rented a, Cliff and
I, because of COVID-19,
we had decided that we
would stay in an Airbnb.
And so we went to Cleveland,
we left, we went to Cleveland
we went to stay in an Airbnb
and normally what will happen
is there is a, the bus
will go to the hotel
'cause the buses stays at the hotel
and then there's our
security team or runner team
will take us back to the Airbnb.
Well, on this particular trip
what wound up happening was
the bus went directly
because we already had
been driving all day,
the bus went directly to the house.
We went to the Airbnb at the house
and because we were doing a
training for groups in Texas,
we set out in front of the
house for about 20 minutes,
did the training went inside.
We were with our videographer
that was doing some interview.
So as we went,
I went upstairs and kept
working on our plan for Detroit,
we were starting to plan
our trip for Detroit.
Cliff, my co-partner was
downstairs doing an interview
and while I was up there on the phone,
I could smell something burning
but what I thought was
that there were some wires
that may have been loose
in the top of that building
and for whatever reason,
silly me, I didn't get
up to go check it out.
And so about five minutes later,
we hear this bang on the door
like they're trying to bang
the door down and we're like,
what is happening, we're starling.
And so we go to the door,
Cliff go to the door
'cause I'm upstairs and
this woman is screaming
and she says, "Get out,
your house is on fire.
Your house is on fire."
We're like, "What are you talking about?"
And sure enough and we could smell it
and so I run downstairs, Cliff goes
and we look in the back of the house
and all we see is fire.
And so he goes inside,
he gets a bucket of water
and he goes to try to take it out.
Now, mind you it's raining outside
so we're like, well,
how did the fire start
and it's raining outside.
And so we call the fire department, 911,
the fire department comes
and they extinguish the fire
and then they start asking us questions.
And what we later found out,
there's a recyclable
bin that's by the house,
the garbage can that's
by the individual house
that was on fire.
And so we don't know,
at first the fire marshal was asking us,
well, was there something in there,
were you all smoking?
And we were like, no, we weren't smoking.
We went in the house,
we didn't do anything.
And later, and then I
wound up telling him,
it was interesting two
things that stuck out to me.
As we were talking I said
and he was like well,
'cause it was (indistinct) outside,
so we moved our campaign bus.
I was like and the bus
has some messages on it
like the word black that some
people may find offensive.
And so when I said that to him,
it was interesting his response
'cause his response was
almost like, oh, I get it.
Like oh okay, then that
makes sense. (laughs)
And I was like, well damn,
we can't even say black, huh?
But anyway and he said, okay
and they brought the arson team.
What was the second thing
that was interesting is,
across the street, they
went across the street
'cause they were trying to get footage
to see who had set the fire
'cause the fence burned,
it could have been a
really bad circumstance.
At this point we had
decided we were gonna leave
and go to a hotel and he
went across the street
and there happened to be a
black family across the street
and there was a woman upstairs
that was yelling out the window saying,
"I am so tired of this,
I am so tired of this.
Every time somebody
black rents that house,
they call the police on 'em.
Every time they keep
harassing those people."
And so the man downstairs
who I don't know what
her relationship with,
but I could tell they were family,
he kept telling her, "Go
back in, go back in."
And so I decided to ask him
but I could tell that there
was some fear from him
and I just kinda asked
him quietly, I said,
"Do you have some rental
problems in this neighborhood?"
I didn't realize we were
staying in a white neighborhood.
And he said, "Yes."
I said, "Do you think
somebody tried to set the house on fire?"
He said, "Why else?"
And I knew he was talking in code to me.
And all of the fire chief
and the arson investigator
is standing there, "Why else
would a trash can by the house
catch on fire in the middle of the rain?"
And he just looked at me.
I said, "Okay, okay.
Do you think that we
probably should leave?"
He said, "Yes."
I was like, "Okay, got it."
He said everything I needed to know.
We knew, you know, it's
interesting because
I think of myself as
someone who is courageous
but racism is traumatic.
This just happened two days ago.
We've had I think 11 events
since then in the same city
the next day we had eight,
I'm still shook to be honest.
I'm sitting here, the idea
that I'm thinking that
just because we got a bus
that has black voters matter on it,
that you would try to
burn us up and kill us.
Just the reality that it is real,
and I can go on with other stories.
Part of, you won't hear a
lot of those stories out
because I've made kind
of the strategic choice
that sometimes I think
violence begets violence
and so a lot of times
when you put it out there,
it creates all these copycats.
And so I don't know if that's
the best choice or the,
I don't know if that's
a good choice or not,
but we don't publicize it as much.
I mean, just even a month ago,
I was in Louisville, Kentucky.
I went there to stand with the
families of Breonna Taylor.
We went to a gospel
concert, we did a training
and we were leaving, a police officer,
well, I'm not sure if
he was a police officer,
may have been a state trooper,
an officer took a picture of the bus,
posted it in some white
groups on Facebook.
My brother's mother is white
and friends with someone in Kentucky,
literally put that there
were riders and thugs
that were coming Kentucky
to tack Kentucky down
and the list went on and
on and on of people saying,
actively looking for the
bus, how they could hurt us,
how they need to cut the tires,
how they needed to do a
road block to really bring,
after that even a intern just
go through the hate emails
and the messages that we get.
Because while we're doing this work
in the spirit of the power
in love, hate is real.
We have pooled up into
places down in South Georgia
where when we pulled up,
just like in the '60s,
the folks in our face will flip the sign
that say we're closed to
keep us from getting gas
or something in a convenience store.
I'm talking about in 2018, 2020.
I've got stories but I can
also tell you the story
about when we went to Randolph County
and when we're in Randolph County,
this woman who was a elder,
they were closing the polling site
and we had a mass meeting
and as we were walking out,
we walk out, she walks out with her cane
and I'm walking kinda assist her
and she looks up at the
bus, I'm actually moved now,
she looks up at the bus and she said,
"Baby does that by say
black voters matter?"
And I said, "Yes, Ma'am because we do,"
and she started crying.
I know why she cried and
I'm saying that because
we cannot act like this
election is another election.
Y'all this ain't enough just
about two different candidates,
we are talking about fascism,
we are talking about the
president of the United States
that literally gave license
to a white nationalist supremacist group
from the debate stage and we're
operating like it's normal,
we're operating as like it's acceptable.
And so I share that
because when we're talking
about moving around in the bus
and when we're talking about
fighting for democracy,
literally we've had to
hire security to go.
I myself, like I'm not just going around.
People can see us and we're that's real,
we're excited and we're doing the work,
but even for us just to have the audacity
to say black voters matter,
there are people that seek
to do us harm, to scare us.
I personally, even at my own
home two maybe a month ago,
received a package that was
handwritten to me to my home,
even though we've gotten my address
scrubbed from the Internet from Russia
so much so that the FBI came to my house.
They got the package, all it
was, what we found out was
it was a little toy like a squishy toy
that had one word that
said Borowski on it.
There wasn't anything dangerous.
They brought the HAZMAT team out.
They took it to the crime lab
but they spent a whole lot of
time and energy and resources
to send something to me that
does not have any value.
I'm raising this because
when you are seeing people,
and I'm not saying this about me,
I'm saying this that
when you're seeing people
who are on the front lines every day
that are literally out there,
they are literally risking their lives,
that we are in a particular
kind of environment
that I don't think we're taking seriously.
That we're not understanding
that when Trump sends the dog whistles
to white supremacists,
you can go to my page,
we've got screenshots
of where there are white
supremacist groups that literally,
a motorcycle group just
the other day, yesterday
that saw the bus at a stop
and said, "We pulled off
'cause we got scared."
I mean just, the bottom line
is there is an environment
that part of what is voter suppression
has been an environment of fear.
And so when we're doing this work,
we have to recognize what is at stake.
This isn't just about an
election and about candidates,
this is literally around
how are we going to shift
the culture of this country
that we uproot racism and
structural racism in a way
that traumatizes, creates
harm and discouragement
to millions of people in this country.
- Hmm, okay, I first wanna say
thank you and we support you
and I'm echoing, this is in the chat
and this is my racial
formations class, LaTosha.
I teach a class that is really about
the foundation of black studies
for first year PhD students
in African-American Studies
and this is from that class cohort.
"Please express our love and gratitude
and support for LaTosha.
Goodness, sending prayers
and positivity and power."
I'm thinking in those stories,
there's so much in both of those stories
and as much as we understand
and is all too well in this moment,
the terror of racism,
we are being terrorized,
we've always been but we
see it in this moment,
the terror of it, the trauma of it.
But I'm also touched by
the will of the elder
who was coming out to vote
and I'm imagining the same sort
of care that you showed her.
You have other examples
of how folks are taking
care of one another
and looking out for one another
in the face of communities
where the police might as well be,
the police are terrorizing
folks as they're voting.
So you cannot rely on the
police as a source of support
or protection against these
violent so-called poll watchers.
And so I'm just wondering
about the ways that,
I guess two questions I wanna ask you,
how you have seen folks be
able to take care of themselves
and show up.
What are the ways that you suggest
for us to think about all of
this in the face of terror
as we're also thinking about
the importance of the vote
and also with that, what can we do?
So a lot of us are in
states, I'm just assuming,
a lot of us on this Zoom are in states
where yes, our vote does matter
but we might not be in
those critical swing states
and I'm wondering what advice
you have for all of us.
So maybe there's lessons from
your travels from the ways
that black folks are
showing up for one another,
but how can we if we're, you know,
what should we do right now?
What should we do beyond voting,
are there ways that we can support folks
in other communities?
What are the most important
things for us to focus on
as we are now, I think it's
33 days out from the election?
The electoral process is happening now,
so we're no longer as you know,
it's no longer election day
we're in election season
but as we approach the
voting day, 33 days out,
what should we be focused on,
what should our eyes be focused on?
Where should our actions be rooted now?
- So just to kind of even build off
even from your last question,
what I wanted to get to is
that at the end of the day,
Dr. King said it, I've
struggled whether I,
particularly a sizable
amount of my adulthood,
whether I believe it or
not, I know it to be true.
Love is the only force
that's greater than hate.
I know that to be true.
And so in that what drives me
and drives the millions of
other folks that we work with,
that are actually doing the
work on the ground is love
and our collective power.
So some of the things that we're doing
even at the polling sites, we've seen it,
'cause oftentimes those same
folks like the Proud Boys,
they're cowards, they're not
used to being challenged,
they're not used to really being able
to come up against collective power,
they're not used to really
being able to be accountable.
And so oftentimes I
think what we have to do
is we have to show our forces
and show up collectively together,
that's the best way to do it.
So I am encouraging folks,
this is part of our,
there was a great question
earlier around whether people,
I'm not one of the ones that I think,
I think that we are not
the, you know, I believe,
oh, I forgot my thought,
the bottom line is that
people are showing up at,
we've got to show up at the poling site.
We've got to say that we
are standing in our power.
The whole purpose of our
We Got Power campaign
is to say that we've got power.
Love is our power, our
resiliency is our power
and I'm not one of those
folks that believe that
we don't have the right to bear arms.
I know I'm not one of those people
that believe that folks of color
should not have protection for themselves.
I will say this though, I
think when we get to the space
that we get in the game of
violence meets violence,
I mean, what are we gonna
do, have a shootout?
I mean, you know what I'm saying?
Like where's the ending sight on that.
And so I think we have to
strategically recognize
that part of what happens
and even with Trump,
when he's really challenged on it,
he talks mad trash when he by himself
and when he's around his
crew but he ain't said that
in a black community yet
about the Proud Boys, right?
My point, because there's
an element of racist
that literally there's
a space of cowardice.
And so what we've seen and experienced
that just having people
at the polling sites,
just having poll workers and poll watchers
that are trained at the polling sites,
that just having people that
are there, that bear witness,
I can tell you, it makes a difference.
It makes a difference how
the people on the inside act,
it makes a difference on how
the people on the outside act,
that in some ways what you've got to do
is you've got to really be
able to go to the process,
be driven not by hate and
fear but be driven by love.
That we love our community
to the extent that we're
gonna protect our community,
that we're going to fight for democracy,
that we're literally going
to do everything in our power
to engage folks.
The fact that right now
there are children in cages
because they've got a
different color passport,
what is wrong with us?
The fact that there were women
who had forced hysterectomies
and are not able to bear children
because they were seeking
refuge in this country
for us to dare to brag on some way
that fundamentally America is the greatest
yet we would do that to other human beings
because of what, passport.
If you ain't mad and pissed
off, something is wrong.
We are literally in this space
that we've got a president office,
I don't care about his economic policy,
I don't care about any of his policy,
the fact that he would use
hate as a vehicle to organize
and keep himself in power,
that's all I need to know.
I'm raising this because we keep operating
as if this is just some
different political election
that oh, it's the Democrat
or the Republicans,
I don't need to hear
another debate, for what?
Fundamentally we know what's at stake
and fundamentally we're
going to have to connect
on how it's gonna be different.
And I do wanna do, I
wanna do something, Aimee,
if it's possible with everybody
that's on this call right now.
I'm just gonna ask you all
if you can just get centered,
I do this all the time, I just
want you all to get centered
wherever you are, just kind
of get centered and grounded.
I'm gonna ask you to close your eyes.
I'm gonna ask you a question.
Keep your eyes closed.
Imagine America without racism.
And I know we don't have much time
so I'm gonna ask you to go
ahead and open your eyes.
How many of you could
actually see something?
I do this exercise all over the place.
I do it at Harvard, I
do it in the community,
I did it on a basketball court last night.
Time and time again 99.9% most of the time
of the people that I ask that question
can't even imagine this
country without racism.
And so my next question to
you is what has been created
and brought into being
in the physical world
that wasn't first envisioned?
This cell phone,
somebody actually had
the see the cell phone
for it to be created.
Someone had to see this
microphone for it to be created.
There is nothing, look around your room,
there's nothing that is in existence
that someone did not envision at first.
I'm raising this because
if we do not shift
and move past just responding to what is
and envision something different,
we will never achieve it
because we can't bring that
into being which we do not.
- LaTosha, can you hear me?
- I know I'm breaking, if
you all can close your eyes
my question is what is
your radical re-imagining
of this nation?
Open your eyes.
That's where we've got
to spend more time y'all.
That's where we've got to spend more time.
We will constantly continue
to be in this rat race
and this hamster wheel
of having the same regenerated
conversations about racism
until we can actually hold
something different in our minds
that we want to actually
bring into the world.
When I talk about, oftentimes
I tell folks around
what is it that we can't reimagine.
That at the end of the day, I
even think about the workweek.
Has anybody ever thought about,
like what's the magic of 40 hours a week?
Like what's the magic of that?
If technology is created so
that it actually cuts down production,
why are we not passing on
the benefits of the means of
production down to the workers?
Why couldn't we, if it
used to take 1,000 workers
to make 100 cars and now
it only takes 10 workers,
I mean, 10 hours to make 100 cars,
why don't we keep all the
workers, cut down their time
and actually give them more money?
That is possible.
We could use technology
where people could work 15
hours a week and make more money
and spend time with their
family and their children.
Most of us until COVID-19
didn't even know our kids.
We know 'em on the weekend
but we didn't see 'em.
They were being raised by a system
that fundamentally is even telling them
oftentimes that they're inferior.
Why can't we reimagine education?
Why can't we reimagine every
single system in this country,
that the economy is not based on
how well the stock market is doing
but how well her people
are doing in this country?
But it will never get there
if we don't radically
reimagine every single system.
And so I can come and talk
about all my challenges
about America and its system.
I can come and talk about what
we need to do in the moment
because this is what we
have right now and so,
but I also have to think of
myself as a black futurist.
I don't have the luxury just
to respond to what is now,
that while I am responding
to what is now, I am off
and pushing my mind to
think about what is possible
because I want to bring it into being
just like Steve Jobs wanted to
bring this iPhone into being,
but it will never happen
if we're not spending time,
not just fighting what is
but creating some space
for us to reimagine.
And so with this, I'll stop.
I'll just say that with this
it's important for us to know
that what's at stake right now,
that oftentimes sometimes we have to make
a tactical decision around
voting that we just give people,
buy them a little space, just
a little grace and space.
They may not be able, that
person that's in office
might not be the person
that's gonna be the person
that we need to make a
transformative change,
they may just be the transitional
person and that's okay
but every single thing
that's available to us,
every single tool.
I love my community and
I love humanity so much
that every single tool that is available,
that is within my reach to use,
I am actively trying to think
how can I use that to provide some space
for people to create that which
I want to see in the world.
And so we've got to also see
this as what we're doing in the meantime
is I see it as a boat
that you're on a big boat,
you're on the Titanic out in the water
and the Titanic is sinking
and all you got is this
little raggedy lifeboat.
That's all you got, that's all you got
but the goal is I got
to make it to the shore
so that I can get to the shore
and I can create that boat
which I know that I
deserved in my communities.
And so we've got to really
be able to be tactical
in how we see elections in
a way that we're not seeing,
do we have the perfect candidate?
We've got to see it around what decision,
'cause a decision is gonna be made,
that is going to create
the least amount of harm
in my community, provide some
protection and some space
while we build this new thing that I call
that grows out of my radical
re-imagining of this nation.
- Hmm, amen.
I mean, I'm just satisfied
because you responded
to my very last question
which was going to ask you
in your Afrofuturistic self
to imagine through your
radical imagination
what we should be thinking
about and working towards,
and you did it but I'm wondering,
this is gonna be a
challenge for you, LaTosha.
But in two minutes there's
like three demographics
that folks are interested in in the chat
and you can pick one or
maybe talk about them,
how they relate together but
folks are talking about felons
and what's happening specifically.
I'm looking at Emma's question,
"Organizations like The Marshall
Project have reported that
many people who are
incarcerated do not register."
I'm wondering your thoughts about that.
There's also a question about
what the South can teach us,
the 21st century south's got to say
or teach the rest of the US
right now in this moment.
And then there was another
question about black women,
black women who give so much
and so much is not poured
back into black women.
So there's a lot there
but I just wanted to--
- I'm trying to do
the speed round.
- I just wanted to voice that.
I'm trying to do
the speed round in two minutes.
So the first thing is I think that
when we're talking about
felony re-franchisement,
I think is the same thing as
I'm talking about earlier,
that fundamentally in a democracy, people,
all people I believe
should have the ability
to be able to make a choice and a decision
about decisions made about them
including those that
have been incarcerated.
And so if you look at the work,
I'm just gonna lead you all
to the work of Desmond
Meade down in Florida,
some of the work that
I did over 10 years ago
was I actually started
the Alabama Coalition
to restore the vote.
And so I think there's
a critical component
around when you look at who's
on the fringes of democracy,
that's actually what points to you
what will strengthen democracy.
And so I think fundamentally,
please look into the work of
Desmond Meade down in Florida.
Second thing is when we're
talking about the South,
so y'all just follow me with this.
When we think about the
financial center in this country,
what do you think about?
Wall Street.
When you think about the
political policy center
in this country, what do you
think about? Washington DC.
When you think about
the entertainment center
in this country, what do you think about?
Hollywood. You don't even
have to think twice about it.
When you think about the
roots of white patriarchy
and supremacy in this country,
what do you think about?
The South, that's right, you're right.
The bottom line is when
we're talking about who is,
you can be as blue as you
wanna be in California
and in New York but who is
running the country right now
and setting policy for the country?
It's actually southern senators.
Mitch McConnell is from where?
Kentucky, right?
Lindsey Graham is from where?
South Carolina.
And so because we've advocated,
when we're talking about the South,
welcome to the South y'all, we
all experiencing it right now
that fundamentally what
we're talking about
is shifting the national
discourse around race
and other issues and policy priorities.
We're allowing southern senators
to actually take control of that process.
They are literally running the country.
It wasn't by accident
that Trump's very first
rally was in Alabama.
And so as long as the roots of racism
allowed to live unchallenged in the South,
that we will continue to
see what we're seeing.
So when we're talking about,
there will be no progressive America
unless we uproot and strengthen
and work in alignment
with folks in the South,
that's just the truth.
We've got the receipts to show that.
And so fundamentally what I say is
the South is red until it ain't.
That fundamentally when
you look at the people,
the numbers that are in North
Carolina and South Carolina
and Alabama, the reason
why the voter suppression
is so great is because
when you look at who's moving down South
and you look up at the demographics
and the demographic shifts,
that that's where our power is.
So when I'm talking about,
we're talking about building
a progressive movement
in this country, that you
uproot the structural racism
in the South, you challenge
that, if you change the South,
as goes to South goes
nation point blank period.
The last and the final point is
I will say that black women
have always been on the vanguard
of fighting for democracy.
We even stood 100 years ago
in the women's suffrage movement
with our white counterparts.
Like let's be honest,
what most don't most
people don't know is that
the abolitionists movement
actually birthed the
women's suffrage movement,
it grew out of the abolitionists movement.
And that in that context,
that while black women were
actually on the vanguard
of supporting that,
that literally it was over 50 years later
before we secured our rights.
And so just as we stood with
our white women counterparts,
it's gonna be interesting to
see whether they stand with us,
and I think that we've got
to put that strategy as well
that fundamentally what black
women have been able to do,
that in the midst of, we understand,
we sit at a particular
intersection of sexism and racism
and our ability to be
able to navigate those
through those worlds
and our ability to tap into our humanity,
I always say, my grandmother told me that,
my great-grandmother was a wet nurse,
like who can have a greater humanity
than to feed of child at your breasts
when your own child can be sold?
Who else has a humanity to nurture
and take care of the very
people who were killing them
and were selling them off?
There is something about
the humanity of black women
that whether this country
acknowledges or not,
I acknowledge it.
I've seen it, we've got
the receipts to show that.
We have been consistent in this country
and so in that, that's why we do,
one of our five principles
of Black Voters Matter
is that we lift up the voices
and the work of black women.
I know I went a little over two minutes
but I tried my best.
- You did that
and you got it all in
and I promised myself
and I promised Tynesha I wasn't gonna cry
and I'm not going to.
I just wanna thank you.
I could not have imagined
thinking about imagination
a better way to kick off
this Endeavor series.
And I love the title,
Black Now: Conversations
for the Revolution.
- I love it.
I just pat myself on the back,
I came up with that but anyway, (laughs)
you embody everything that
we need so desperately
in this moment and beyond, LaTosha.
You are history, you are so
much of what we need right now
and you're always pointing us to,
you're forcing us to not
just imagine what we need
but to create that very thing
and you are modeling that right now,
you are creating that
very thing that we need.
I'm so grateful for you, I'm
so grateful that you exist,
that you are here to teach us,
that we can learn from you.
I about to teach a
class now and I can not,
I mean, I don't know,
we're just gonna talk about
what you just said.
You just laid it all out for us.
Thank you, thank you, thank
you from the bottom of my heart
and I just wanna tell everybody here
there will be more conversations,
Endeavors is on and popping.
LaTosha got us started.
Our next Endeavors
conversation is October 22nd,
that's with Emily Wang.
We'll be talking about justice and health.
Again, something else that LaTosha,
I know you're working on
as you work through all
of these communities.
We are sending you protection,
we are sending you light.
We are covering you as you
move through this country
on your bus, know that we are holding you
and please, please,
please, I know you are,
but please continue to
take care of yourself
and we will see you on the other side.
- I will see you all.
Thank you so much.
- I just wanna say love will win.
If y'all don't remember
anything else I say,
that love will win.
When I'm looking at the
screen, even right now,
the beautiful faces, and it is this,
the diversity is our strength.
This is what America looks like.
That stage wasn't reflective
of what America looks like,
you know, that debate stage,
this is what America looks like.
And so I just wanna encourage you all
to really spend some time
radically re-imagining, you know,
working through this process,
standing in a space of love.
We're being attacked right
now, not because we're losing,
we're actually winning
y'all, we're winning
and there's nothing they're
gonna be able to do about it.
We've just got to be clear
about letting this moment,
you know, the last thing I'll
say is what a diamond is.
All diamond is is a piece of
coal put under extreme pressure
over time that becomes a
diamond and what does it gain?
It gains clarity.
So I'm hoping that in this
moment of great pain and pressure
that we allow this pressure and this pain
to really be able to turn it into clarity,
a sense of clarity for
us so that we go forward
and we radically reimagine this country.
So love y'all, thank you so much.
When we worked together, we win.